after the first world war was over
Germany found itself in pretty dire
circumstances it no longer had a Kaiser
and so had to determine what sort of
government it was going to have it was
facing economic political and military
disaster and also it had to conform to
the Treaty of Versailles which saw
Germany lose these lands restricted the
size of its military prevented said
military from being stationed in the
Rhineland which was also occupied and
importantly ordered the payment of
future operations after the German
revolution in the wake of its
capitulation was defeated Germany
emerged as a democratic republic among
his economy was basically in the toilet
because the Allies didn't value the
German currency the Papio market was
demanded in 1921 that these reparations
be paid in other ways either in gold or
in foreign currencies nathie ver of
those weren't viable in raw materials
the German government at this point led
by Yosef verve had a great idea
let's just print more money with which
we can buy more foreign currency to pay
the Allies what could go wrong anyway
even with this foolproof economically
viable approach of simply just having
more money Germany kept falling behind
on its payments which upset the French
and the Belgians who wanted their money
because of the horrors that they had to
enjoy during the First World War
yet the British and the Americans argued
for the reparations to either be halted
or reduced since Germany likely couldn't
pay them France had put pressure on
Britain to aid it in sanctioning Germany
for missed payments but the British
refused furthermore in April 1922
Germany in the USSR signed the Treaty of
Rapallo which ended both States
international isolation and also
terrified the French in November of the
same year Germany failed again to
deliver a shipment of raw materials to
France and so the French Prime Minister
and former president Raymond Wong Kar a
opted to take firm action in early 1923
French troops moved into this area
called the Ruhr Valley which included
major cities like Dusseldorf and
Dortmund and contained a great deal of
Germany's industrial might there were
several reasons why France opted to
occupy these lands the first was that
France needed the money
France had debts to the United States
and needed German reparations in order
to pay them another reason was that
France along with Belgium was utterly
terrified of a research in Germany in
fact that any breach of the Treaty of
Versailles should be met with firm
action now Frances invasion was met with
anger in Germany whose government
declared a state of emergency it urged
those living there to passively resist
the French by simply refusing to work no
workers in the factories meant no output
which meant France and Belgium would get
exactly nothing in order
to aid the workers who would be on
strike the government promised to pay
their wages which they would do by
simply printing more money now not all
citizens were content to get on with
their daily lives and ignore the French
and there were often clashes between the
French soldiers there in the rows
inhabitants this sometimes led to French
troops killing civilians which or global
opinion change and many began to see
France as the largest threat to the new
European peace Britain was particularly
critical of the occupation and
franco-british relations were damaged
severely when Britain's first Labour
Prime Minister Ramsay MacDonald came to
power in 1924 he was extremely critical
of the French and he helped the London
conference with Chhabra to negotiate an
end to the ongoing crisis in the end the
French folded on everything and agreed
to leave the rule within a year and to
take no more money from the area it also
agreed to the American Dawes plan which
reduced Germany's war reparations and
dealt with the ongoing hyperinflation
crisis there which is what happens when
government simply tried to print more
money forever
anywhoo France left the Ruhr Valley in
1925 having failed to achieve any of its
goals in the end its fears of a
resurgent Germany able to willingly
violate the Treaty of Versailles were
realised Germany and Britain saw Frances
are destabilizing and aggressive force
in Europe and both would see their
foreign policies affected by this and
whilst no one can be said to have won
the rural crisis it seems pretty certain
that France lost it I hope you enjoyed
this episode and thank you for watching
with the special thanks to my patreon
supporters who you can see on screen
here and with an extra special thanks to
James Bissonnette David archaeologists
party Boyko Danny Maloney
Colin Castleman Rob Waterhouse Aaron the
white Michael Reynolds each way an
emperor chris wicker Gustav Swan
Gareth Turner spinning three plates
David Silverman Winston Cawood Maggie
packs Kowski Christian check' Anthony
Beckett
Robert Wetzel Skye Chappell and Ike